[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
we're now getting a closer look at the
mbc traffic stop made during the kylo
ren house trial this is officer jones
canoes police
it's kind of trying to figure out what's
going on here why you have a reporter or
producer following vehicles out here and
could the historical roe v wade ruling
be overturned the supreme court hears
arguments to reverse the famed abortion
law plus a defendant's chilling reaction
to the news of his wife's death there
was no verbal or emotional response
he just looked at me with with really no
response at all and later this kind of
thing can happen anywhere and sadly it
happened even in a sweet quiet community
like oxford the latest on the deadly
school shooting out of oxford michigan
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin msnbc was barred from the
courthouse during kyle rainhouse's trial
after a freelance producer was caught
following the bus carrying jurors now
we're getting a look at the traffic stop
lawn crimes anjanet levy is here with
the video
brian no one has been charged with a
crime related to that producer following
the jury bus kenosha police say that's
because they pulled over james morrison
for running a red light and that
actually prevented any possible jury
tampering take a look at this this is
the video released by kenosha police the
police blurred morrison's face before
releasing that body camera video
morrison is answering questions
throughout it now you may recall judge
bruce schroeder who presided over
rittenhouse's trial called the incident
a serious matter at one point during the
traffic stop morrison holds up letters
he said the clerk of courts was going to
give to the jurors requesting an
interview after the verdict morrison
said booking producer irene bion told
him to follow the bus and she speaks by
phone to the officer
i was being called by new york going
maybe
people need to follow but i don't know i
was trying to
you trying to what
just do what they told me to do new york
told you to follow a vehicle yeah we
were just trying to respectfully um just
trying to see if it's um
if it's possible to
um
to find any leads about um
about
the case and so we were we
uh we were just keeping our distance um
just to see like where
um
people involved in the in the trial
are positioned by no means were we
trying to get in contact with any of any
of the jury members
now i reached out to an nbc news
spokesperson for a comment and to see
whether irene bion still worked at the
network no one responded to that email
requesting a comment now when this
happened a couple of weeks ago that nbc
news spokesperson said morrison never
contacted or photographed the jurors and
never intended to do so the spokesperson
said at the time that the network
regretted the incident brian
thanks angenet joining us today is legal
analyst dina dahl and terry austin deana
your reaction to this video and why is
the man's face blurred
well my first reaction was good for them
because they did a great job of catching
a car that was following a jury you know
in this very high profile case they had
no idea what the intent was behind the
car you know now we know there was this
reputable news agency behind it but
still you know we have to really protect
the juror's identity the jury integrity
so good on them for catching uh this
incident uh in terms of the blurring i
think that is because they haven't
charged um this person with any crime so
there's really no reason to have his
identity
be public yeah they got this point for
james morrison he's pretty lucky that uh
his friends and family aren't seeing his
face because at this point it's just a
traffic ticket looks like uh morrison
might have just blown through a red
light if anything but you're right you
know there's no real criminal charges
there for james morrison terry does
judge schroeder's ban on msnbc now make
more or less sense after you've seen
this video
it makes sense to me brian this is a
serious issue if in fact there was any
intent to tamper with the jury i usually
haven't been agreeing with judge
schroeder's decisions but here i think
that he did make a good decision to ban
that network there are multiple
considerations here i mean was it a
traffic violation was it a breach of a
court order or was it just a
journalistic ethical breach either way
what the judge was trying to do was to
protect the jury and also to protect the
integrity of that actual trial the last
thing you want is for something to
happen with the jury and to have a
mistrial so i think the judge made a
good decision he's setting a precedent
here he's trying to say to the media
look you can go so far but you can't go
over the line so all in all i think it
made a lot of sense speaking of over the
line and jeanette you're a reporter
who's covered high profile cases is this
how a producer like james morrison
should be chasing down stories
no
not at all you can get a good look if
you want to see what the jurors look
like you can look at them in the
courtroom and they had the opportunity
to do that say you wanted to get a good
look at them if to try to approach them
for an interview afterwards but during a
trial stay away from the jurors you're
just asking for trouble you can always
approach them afterward and in the video
as i mentioned you saw that he had
letters that the clerk of courts was
going to give to the jurors after the
verdict came in saying if you want to
talk with me here is my information so
there was really no need to chase them
down like that i think they were just
trying to get a look at them and maybe
try to approach them later for an
interview all right no reason to chase
him down james thank you very much
everyone on to federal court in new york
where attorneys for british socialite
elaine maxwell cross-examined one of her
accusers the victim referred to only as
jane told the jury maxwell helped
jeffrey epstein sexually abuse her for
three years starting when she was 14.
but on cross maxwell's lawyers
questioned jane's memory after she
testified the socialite touched her
breast they say jane previously told the
government she couldn't remember whether
maxwell touched her jane also said she
recalls meeting prince andrew and donald
trump but did not accuse them of
wrongdoing three more accusers are
expected to testify maxwell maintains
her innocence epstein died by suicide in
2019 while awaiting trial
now to minnesota where the trial for
ex-cop kim potter completed its second
day of jury selection as of wednesday
eight jurors four men and four women
have been seated in the trial six of the
jurors are white one is asian and one is
black in all there will be 12 jurors
with two alternates potter faces
manslaughter charges for the shooting
death of dante wright during a traffic
stop just outside minneapolis in april
wright was being pulled over for an
expired registration tag when officers
determined he had an outstanding warrant
they attempted to take him into custody
body camera footage shows wright
resisting when potter warns him she will
tase him but instead of pulling out a
stun gun she pulls out her gun and
shoots right in the chest right a black
man was unarmed at the time potter's
defense argues that shooting death was
an accident say with law and crime
network for gavital gower coverage of
the trial
still ahead on law and crime daily
prosecutors pushed to send bill cosby
back to prison after his conviction was
overturned we hear directly from the
actor and comedian spokesman person next
but first a conservative majority in the
supreme court could bring sweeping
changes to abortion rights as justices
hear arguments which could overturn roe
v wade details in washington still ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back the u.s supreme court hears
arguments that could end in roe v wade
being overturned the landmark case
legalized abortion in 1973. supreme
court justices ruled states cannot ban
abortions before viability or when a
fetus can survive outside of the womb
viability is now considered between 22
and 24 weeks mississippi officials say
scientific advances allow babies to
survive earlier wednesday's arguments
focus on a mississippi law that bans
abortions more than 15 weeks after
conception last month the supreme court
heard arguments over a similar texas law
which bans abortions after about six
weeks of pregnancy the court could issue
rulings in both cases in june or july
back to discuss mississippi's challenge
of roe v wade is legal analyst dina dahl
and terry austin terry mississippi seems
to be arguing that an abortion at 24
weeks is too long and that it should be
around 15 weeks what's the heart of the
argument here
well that's exactly what they are
arguing they're saying that a woman's
right to have an abortion should be
narrowed from the 24 weeks that was
established in roe v wade when the fetus
is viable to the shorter 15 weeks when
actually some women may not even
recognize the fact that they are
pregnant so
the one thing about the argument is that
the state strategy changed to arguing
for a complete overturn of roe v wade
and justice roberts basically said that
it was a switch and bait he was very
frustrated about the states changing
their strategy
notwithstanding that brian it does look
as though chief justice roberts might
lean in favor of narrowing it to 15
weeks and there are other conservative
judges who are going to probably rule in
that way as well dina speaking of
justices justice sotomayor made a point
that mississippi said they made this law
because the conservative state that
being mississippi said scotus has quote
new justices
what do you think of her point that
scotus shouldn't be controlled by
politics
i think she said the thing that all of
us lawyers are thinking you know the
supreme court is having a major
pr image right now it started with the
decision in bush vigor it continued with
the struggle with the nominations with
obama and trump and this particular case
has
many people fired up on both political
sides no matter what the legal
foundation will be with whatever their
decision will be the takeaway will be
that this is political and her point is
right that this
will probably harm the reputation of the
court if they decide to overturn roe v
wade no matter how justified those
conservative justices may feel in their
decision we'll see how the decision
comes up and when it does we'll be sure
to report it here on law and crime daily
at the supreme court prosecutors want
justices to reinstate the sexual assault
conviction for comedian bill cosby back
in june cosby was released from prison
when his conviction was overturned the
ruling was based on a verbal immunity
agreement made in 2005 that qazi would
not face charges when a woman claimed he
had drugged and sexually assaulted her
but in 2015 the actor was arrested after
the original investigation was dropped
and a settlement had been reached
between the woman and cosby prosecutors
now say supreme court justices should
throw out that ruling arguing the
overturned conviction was made over a
questionable agreement long crimes
angina levy sat down with cosby
spokesperson who says montgomery county
district attorney kevin steele has an
obsession with the case
it was shocking it just shows that this
district attorney cabin still has a true
obsession uh it's a true crime obsession
believe it or not with uh mr cosby this
is the same district attorney who ran
the willie horton campaign and said if
you elect me i would bring bill cosby to
justice when he knew that mr cosby had a
deal mr cosby waived his fifth amendment
rights settled out of court for 3.8
million dollars for andrea constant
never to be charged and this guy became
an overzealous prosecutor and you know
he's a detriment not only to montgomery
county but his constituents
coming up the prosecution builds his
case in the new hampshire verse william
rg murder trial plus another student
dies after a tragic shooting at a high
school in michigan what authorities have
learned in their investigation so far
straight ahead on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily in
day three of new hampshire versus
william bill argy first responders told
the jury how argy reacted to the news
that his wife was dead
prosecutors say 46 year old r.g killed
his wife maureen back in 2019. they say
he strangled or suffocated her after
that they say he attempted suicide ran
off and gambled at a casino argy's
defense maintains his wife committed
suicide and that he found her in bed
with a sheet around her neck argue was
the sole beneficiary of his wife's 400
thousand dollar life insurance policy on
wednesday witnesses for the prosecution
took the stand including the officer who
told argy his wife had been killed
when you first met with the defendant
did you tell him that his wife was dead
i did and what was the defendant's
reaction when you told him that his wife
was dead
um
there was no verbal or emotional
response
um
he just looked at me uh with with really
no response at all according to the
defendant who had discussed directly had
been discussing divorce
um initially um
he he had brought up um divorce back in
2015 2016. um
they seemingly had worked through those
issues
and more recently uh maureen had brought
up that she wanted this divorce
as legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry austin terry what do you think
about the officer's explanation as to
when he gave
argy his miranda warnings
i think the officer actually gave a very
good explanation he said he was being
cautious he actually met with the
defendant in the hospital and he was
brought to the hospital while he was
with the police so
i think the officer was trying to say
that he wanted to make sure that the
defendant did not think he was in
custody there and he didn't want the
defendant to incriminate himself he
wanted to make sure that he understood
all his rights he wasn't under arrest
but he provided him with the miranda
rights just so at the end of the day
that interview would not be questioned
at any point in time so i thought it was
a good move make sense doubting your
eyes and crossing your teeth dina what
do you make of rg's reaction to his
wife's death and how will either side
argument
you know the defendant said that he
untied his wife because he didn't want
the children to see her like that and
then he went to this casino the judge
ruled that his fleeing the scene and
going to the casino can be used as
evidence for men's rhea for intent which
is very strong for the prosecution all
right we'll see how the prosecution uses
that information of course this is their
witness so obviously they think it's a
benefit to them but thank you both for
your input when we come back a 15 year
old suspect behind bars in the oxford
michigan school shooting we bring you
the latest on the deadly shooting as
authorities search for a motive
[Music]
welcome back new videos released showing
dozens of hours of interviews in the
andrew cuomo's sex crimes investigation
on monday the new york attorney
general's office released transcripts
and video interviews to the public from
an investigation that wrapped up in
august the video comes one month after a
criminal complaint was filed against the
former new york governor on charges of
sexual misconduct nearly a dozen women
both current and former employees of the
state have accused cuomo of sexual
harassment independent investigators
appointed by a new yorker attorney's
attorney general say cuomo did harass
multiple women hours of video testimony
show cuomo's reaction to the
investigation as he denied any
wrongdoing and said the alleged actions
could be based on perception
there was never a suggestion
that i wanted to date charlotte
all right i mean just to think about it
that was never
the concept of
grooming
nothing happened but i felt like we were
on a
path to something may be happening
she felt that way
i understand that i respect it
but this is all her perception right
cuomo resigned as governor in august
after a decade in office he is now
facing a misdemeanor sex crime complaint
that alleges he forcefully touched a
woman last december the latest now on a
school shooting in michigan a fourth
victim has now succumbed to their
injuries the shooting happened tuesday
afternoon at oxford high school about 45
minutes outside of detroit three
students were killed and a and several
more injured the fourth victim died on
wednesday investigators say they are
still trying to determine a motive for
the 15-year-old sophomore who opened
fire at his high school deputies
arrested the shooting suspect within
minutes of arriving at the school in
response to a flood of 9-1-1 calls
investigators reveal that his father
purchased a gun just days before the
shooting on black friday in a press
conference the oakland county sheriff
praised the quick emergency response
time
one of our deputies because of the
severity of wounds loaded up one of the
children in his car and sadly that child
died in the car
one of our employees who was in the 911
center as part of the team taking the
emergency calls
had a relative killed in the attack
and so this touches us all personally
and deeply and will for a long time this
wound will never go away
and we understand that but we also want
the community to know that we're here
for them
and we will leave no stone unturned in
determining all the things that led up
to it and making sure that this
investigation is full and complete
dina what do you think the investigation
to a mass shooting like this in michigan
will look like
i mean there's already quite a bit that
they know i mean this tragedy you know
occurred with these students who were
vulnerable and they saw this shooter the
shooter has been arrested it's true that
his parents aren't having him aren't
allowing him to be questioned by police
but there's already quite a bit that the
police know they know the gun that was
used and it was purchased by his father
so you know in terms of the
investigation there may be a little bit
more that they can find out in terms of
motive but they certainly already have
enough information absolutely especially
enough to at least go forward with some
initial charges terry he's just a high
school sophomore but
what is the prosecution against his team
going to look like and could the boy's
father face charges too
absolutely you know the prosecutor is
going after this with full force
charging him as an adult and they stated
the reason they're charging as an adult
is because the crime was so serious it
was not an impulsive act and so
the end of the day they shot 11 and
killed four and so the fact is the
parents could very well be brought in
you know that the parents you mentioned
brian bought the gun just very recently
they didn't protect the gun from their
son one of the things i'll also say is
during the arraignment they came on zoom
and they wore baseball caps to me that
is a sign of disrespect it does not seem
as though they are cooperating with the
authorities and based on all of that i
do think that if the prosecution can
find enough information against the
parents they too will be charged yeah
like you said not having protections for
the gun that could be a charge of itself
but thank you dean and terry and thank
you for joining us here on law on crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you